all right hello everyone happy Friday
welcome to CS 109 now I am not the usual
person Chris is here he as well it is
uh it is only customary for the head TAA
to give the lecture on algorithmic
analysis so in in continuing with that
tradition here I am and we have a good
amount of content today so the coverage
today will be um expectation uh law of
to law of total expectation we have five
problems prepared today of those five
one of them is extremely difficult so
I'll give a bit of a heads up and a
warning before that throw throw around
some some candy get some goost going for
that problem and then afterwards it's
more or less of a it's more or less
straightforward so yeah let's have a
good time happy Friday hope uh hope the
last week was
good cool oh by the way so the so the so
the briary today is we got kid Kats and
we got and we got some chocolate
truffles and I'll throw I'll throw these
in uniform uniform random distribution
weighted by how many there are
okay all right and with that let's get
started a little bit about what happened
last time um there's a null hypothesis
um so how can we use Bo boost trapping
to deal with null hypothesis uh uh so
this will be a little bit of a review
but the idea is we have this thing
called A P value and the one kind of
Crystal idea that we really wanted to
get across is the P value is the
probability that your hypothesis is from
noise and that's why we do that's why we
can do bootstrapping with like
replacement as samples just to say hey
if I got these two different samples and
I just take like subsamples with
replacement what is the what is the
probability that I'll actually see the
the hypothesis that we're trying to to
claim just out of random noise that's it
P stands for oh what did I just click I
didn't click anything okay P stands for
what's the probability that your
hypothesis is just from noise that's it
okay all right so on to the main topic
for today algorith algorithmic analysis
and one of the in one of the problems of
the five that I said we'll cover today
is pertinent to Netflix streaming so in
particular the caching system that
Netflix has had up until I believe like
a year or two ago when it switched over
to AWS but that's some those are things
in the news but we'll see we'll see how
they actually like stream some of the
videos okay so but first we should do a
little bit of a review especially about
um expected
values uh so fundamental definition of
expected Val value how do you calculate
the expected value of a r a variable and
here we're we're assuming that it is
discret so we take a sum over X is the
value that each kind of varable can take
on probability that and the P
probability that X takes on that value
is just like P of x x okay this should
all be review this was like from from
material from before the midterm okay so
a little bit more General than just the
expectation is linearity of expectation
so when you have the sum of some random
variables you can just carry you can
just carry the expectation into each one
of the terms so the why is there two
clickers on this interesting um so the
the expectation that of a sum of random
variables is equal to the sum of the
expectation now we'll be seeing this a
lot in class today like I think there's
at least like five other the sides that
have this particular like like like that
have like switching this little e with
this big capital Sigma that kind of
looks like a e so if you're like the Big
E little e switch just a few sides of
this
okay so here's one kind of limitation
about what we can do with expectation um
the issue with expectation is it tries
to capture all of the characters of a
probability distrib of a probability
distribution using a single value so
this is good and bad good as in if we if
the underlining distribution is just way
too hard to capture we can at least give
some kind of a reasoning about it the
bad is it's a single number like I can
tell you what the expectation here is of
this big curve but sometimes what we
really care about is like okay what is
going on in this like 7,000 range it's
like that's that's your tail like you
should really be optimizing for your
tail in certain situations too so we'll
talk a little bit about like how that
kind of plays into like like software
selling or so but this is the primary
limitation of
expectation okay all right so couple
other things law of unconscious
statistic just expectation of a function
on some random variable X is equal to
the sum of the function on the values
that X can take on multiplied by their
probabilities and then one particular
example that we see probably like I
think on the midterm two was when we're
calculating the variance the term the
terms are expectation of X squ like X
random variable Square minus the the
expectation of X the random variable all
squared and for that first term the way
you calculate it is you just take the
output of any of the ex any of the event
values exit sorry any of the values that
big X can take on little X's Square it
and then multiply it by the
probability okay so there's a lot of
unconcious satis the the idea is like so
it's quite simple and an an unconscious
sa satis station could do it but it's
debatable but now we can like recognize
it immediately in the
wild okay so that's all for review and
here are some like kind of like practice
problems and revisiting a few of the
random variables that we've seen so
far so first first of all let's start
with bu so let's let's say we have some
events E1 through n and they're
indicator random variables okay so what
does an indicator mean indicator means
beri okay and if each of the beri random
variables occur with like okay if they
occur your bruli is going to take on
value one if it doesn't occur then it's
going to be zero
okay so we we have said in the past that
the expectation of whatever the r
whatever the brly random variable is is
equal to just the probability of the Val
of the like
event yes how do we know the indicator
means oh it's defined so it's the yeah
it's defined like the indicator is
really defined as the indicator is
defined to be the function where if the
random variable occurs it's one if the
random variable does not occur it's zero
okay yeah this pops up in two examples
so we should like like we should clarify
that now okay so why is this the case we
take the so we just expand using the
expectation like take okay the two
values that the that the Bly random
variable can take on is zero or one
multiply them by by the probabilities
and take a sum okay that's it so here's
a here's a term that that should be used
a little bit earlier but PRI also known
as the indicat ROM variable where was
studied by like the guy named George
Bull and uh bull actually died of being
too cool like he uh like this is exactly
how like he uh he died he died of
pneumonia after walking around in the
rain in Queen in I think like Queen's
University or something in England okay
so uh in other words don't run out in
the rain and be cold like I think I've
seen like two rain storms here in like
the past quarter or something so like
like take care of yourselves like if you
if like don't like don't don't be
running around in the water right it's a
it's a b it's a big coal for that don't
get ponia
Okay
so a little bit harder uh binomial so
we've like kind of alluded to or at
least I've alluded to my section that a
binomial is just a sum of brly random
variables so one thing that we could
take is okay take take each brly random
variable take the probability say this n
independent Trials of them um Define the
indicat Define like the indicator
variable over them by the way indicated
variable BR R variable they're like kind
of really really similar here say say
each bruli is is say each indictive
variable is from a bruli take the sum
over them okay so this is the sum and Y
here is actually a binomial so y can be
defined as both the binomial here or it
can be defined as the sum of Bly random
variables okay with the same P for each
one of the bis IID Etc okay how do we
take the expectation of this we take the
expectation on the outside of the sum
switch the Big E and the little e and we
get and we get the get that the
expectation it's just the expectation of
the sum is the sum of the expectations
which is just n of the random variables
times the probabil times the probability
for each okay make
sense all right cool expectation of a
negative binomial so in class we've seen
that the negative binomial is the number
of Trials until you see R successes okay
until you see R successes can also be
model like okay so R successes each one
of them is like the number of Trials
success after after the I minus first
success those can be modeled as
geometrics and then the negative
binomial is actually just a sum of the
geometric random random variables okay
so as a pattern with B with bom uh
binomi random variables we will be
taking the expectation over these and
just switch around the sum and the
expectation and we get that the
expectation of a negative binomial is
exactly as we would expect our trials
divided by toal probability P for
each
okay make sense well good we're just
using the same trick over and over again
just swap your expectation with your sum
this is a key idea we use this all the
time all the time in 109 it's uh pretty
important
okay so with that let's move on into the
first of the five problems that we have
today computer cluster utilization so
consider if you have a computer cluster
with K servers that means you have like
K little desktop Towers running some
program or you have one single desktop
Tower running five different running K
different
programs requests are independently go
go into each server so some so call one
of the servers server I with some
probability Pi okay let AI be the event
that is server I has no requests okay so
actually maybe it would be helpful to do
board work for this
[Applause]
one so if I get the so if I have these
like five different servers right
or four of them for now and just like S1
S2 S3 S4 okay and then the number of
requests that I have can be like R1 R5
r10 okay the other one because the other
ones have got have gone process or so S1
here does not have does not have a
single request is processing so it's
sitting idle so in this case a the a
indicator variables would just be A1
equals 1 because it's true that S1 is
blank then there's A2 oh by the way is
this too small for people to
C okay
cool A2 is zero dot dot dot dot dot all
of these are all A4 is zero as well
because they all have a requested
servicing so each of these A's just
monitors if a server is Idle or
not
okay so X is going to be the number the
total the sum of A1 through AK so the
total number of servers that are idle
and the thing that we want to kind of
monetize or the thing that we're like
really interested in is what is the what
are the number of servers that are
actually doing useful work at at this
like point in time with this many
requests so the question here is how do
we go on ahead how do we go on ahead and
solve for the expected number of servers
y that are not vacant given like some
certain number of
requests Okay so so let's see okay so
maybe like take a minute or two discuss
a little bit and see how we can kind of
solve for expected value of y
here yeah maybe like turn turn to your
neighbor find some
find uh find someone nearby to talk to
you or just like shot that
answer
so it's not the expectation of a single
add
because
okay maybe let's come back and uh Sol
solve this as a group a little bit
so Y is defined as so okay so I went ah
and cheat a little bit and like click
clicked on the clicker for a little bit
of a start so Y is defined as just K the
total number of servers we have minus
those that are
Idol so by linearity of expectation we
can just say Okay expectation Y is equal
to the expectation of K expectation of
constant is a
constant and then and then propagated to
the expectation of
X so here okay now we just need to solve
for the expectation of X
okay um for the expectation of X we know
that okay so what do you know about x x
is the number of events of A1 through a
k and their indicators
okay
so that's just going to be the
expectation of the sum
over all over all the indicators
okay does that make sense anybody have
any
questions yes where's the formula for y
coming
from here uh request yeah it's equal to
yeah this is a it's just given yeah it's
given a logical reason why that's the
yeah totally if the if x is the number
of servers with zero requests the number
of servers with more than zero with like
more than zero requests are all the
other servers right so there's K total
servers X of them are idle and we're
looking for the ones that are not idle
so that's just K minus X yeah okay oh I
should be giving upes here kick that oh
my yeah okay any other questions I got
PL I got plenty of K of kiat
here can can you just repeat again
what
VI uh VI so VI is the broli indicator
for some for the AI so actually AI here
can already be can can already be
modeled as a brol just by itself but we
explicitly say hey we know that this
event AI that like a server I does not
have like a request is either a true or
false but to kind of cast that true or
false a one or a zero we need to say
that it's an indicator like this is
useful for if you for if you have if you
make an assumption over like what the
pro over like the probability of like
your case servers being idle or not and
in this case it's kind of like okay like
semantically we could just say AI equals
like bi equals Ai and it will be the
same
difference okay yes can we always just
encapsulate all of the individual terms
in linear equation as expectations and
are there any specific cases where we
can't do this because we had Y is equal
K - x yeah and then we just apply the
expectation to both sides we have the
value that's always going to be valid oh
yes yes yes it's always valid even like
KX it could like X be dependent on k k
could be dependent on X if you have a
subtraction and you have and you were
interested in expectation just propagate
that expectation to to each term
expectation is linear which is like
super
cool
okay oh sorry okay
anyways okay so okay we we we do the
usual thing we swap in the the
expectation into the sum then we
calculate okay what's the expectation of
each one of the indicated ROM variables
it's going to it's going to be the
probability of
B that's just equal to the the uh the
probability of each of each request
going into a server times the number of
service there are or sorry times the
number of requests there are n or to the
power n and then there's going to be K
of those so that's
it you
like like there are n so there are n n
requests the probability that one of
them will go into each server is one
minus p is 1us pi and then and we can
and then there are K different servers
so we just sum across
them okay
yes when you
go to is
that exactly yeah so when so to repeat
the question going from E of bi to P of
AI here this is this is because the boli
the expectation of beri is just a pi
it's is a
probability
okay
all right so why is this important
because so Amazon actually uses this in
AWS they say the number of ser the
number of servers that are occupied at
all times and the number of servers that
are idle at all times has a direct
impact on their efficiency and how much
money they're spending on their W on
like AWS like Compu Computing warehouses
and they can actually monetize this and
okay yeah there's a drone there's a
drone that I made a while ago but the
important thing is AWS web services is
actually 52% of all of their like profit
like that's more than they're like whole
North American Commerce operations so
like everything that we use on like the
Amazon website that's like they make
less money from that than they do from
just like AWS like services so like the
idea is like they rent out these
computers they're like elastically sized
for for consumers to kind of like rent
out the computers and they can make they
can make money in the fact that your
consumers are not going to always be
using using your
computers so like there like you could
you could Shuffle around the consumers
on each computer and make money off off
a t off a like kind of renting out
compute
okay all right so yeah that that was
pretty cool this is a pretty big game
game changer a lot of people started
doing like cloud computing for this like
Azure gcp or
AWS
um yeah okay so okay so remember how I
said I'd give a warning before the
problem that's going to be the hardest
in this whole lecture so a little bit of
background about this particular problem
it's it's a name problem so there's a so
we gave this problem out I think a few
years ago in like a final exam and I
cannot and well it was very difficult
there's uh it's it's partic it's
particularly famous and I've actually
like when I first got the slides I like
wrote out a few like quite a few more
slides just to kind of give it like more
motivation about like why this problem
is important so if the last if the last
like example kind of like we went a bit
too fast on is because like I really
kind of wanted to like save some time
for like this particular example okay so
before before we start with this one
anybody want a kit
cat oh my God okay this is gonna all
right can I deliver the kit cat yeah
sure yeah okay or you can just okay okay
here here uh here
go one here okay all right okay let's go
to the back okay so there's two this
way there's looks like huh let's see one
two three that
way sorry okay this is probably not
going to work but okay we're going
to
okay keep
it okay okay there was a spread okay BR
the that's a no that's a
no
huh oh yeah oh I'll put it uh it's
here
okay that's actually code okay all right
so let uh
okay let's hit the heart let's hit the
hard question then get some get some
glucose it's a Friday let's not let's
not check out just yet for the weekend
all right so here's a little bit here's
another key for this problem okay when
you when when stuck just brainstorm
about random variables it will be very
good to like kind of like okay just like
start thinking of very creative random
variables because like when I saw this I
was thinking geez I could not do this on
a final but okay
so here's a premise you got a hash table
with nend
buckets
okay you have a set of strings each
string is equally likely to get hash
into any
bucket so just like you you you have a
very good hash function that just
equally distributes these strings
okay let X be the number of strings to
Hash until each bucket has more than or
equal to one
string
okay what is the expected value of the
number of of the number of times you're
going to have to Hash A
String that's it
this singular
question has a name it's called it's
typically called the coupon collector
problem and I've seen it in about like
two or three classes first time I saw it
was in 109 second two times were were in
like other CS Theory classes pretty
popular it's got a really it's got a
really nice solution but it takes quite
a bit of motivation to if you're sing it
for the first
time okay so to kind of demonstrate
here's a hash function here's here's
five buckets all right we're going to
start hashing some strings and see and
get some like get a little bit of like
motivation about how we can solve this
so we have a string okay here's a string
our like our CS online students are the
best we hash it and it gives us a and it
gives us a little sun in the first
bucket by the way this is going to be
like all the strings are going to be
like subliminal messaging for like a for
like a like a please feel gun on a
Friday okay so this is round one okay so
X here is like X here has okay it's not
X but like the number of rounds here
that that has happened is one because
we've only hash one
string okay here's string here's round
number two we hash this other string
into the third into the third or fourth
Bucket over here index by one index by
zero then we hatch another string and
this is round three so now we have a
collision and we put and we put two suns
in in in the first
box
okay then on the third on the the third
one or on the fourth one we hash uh we
hash another drink and it puts a smiley
face and yes please eat fruits it's a
it's a there there there's sickness
going around hopefully this will
help um this puts so this puts a smiley
face into one of the other into one of
the other buckets the only two buckets I
have to cover now is the bottom bucket
here and a middle bucket here once you
cover those two we're done
okay so we hash another strink and and
we finally get a get a little symbol in
the bottom in the bottom
bucket but we hash another like okay so
now we'll be done if we Hash A String
into like the third into like the middle
the middle bucket
right yeah but s but sadly I put a heart
in like a little weird place because we
need a space for another heart so we
don't actually get what we want we have
another
Collision okay and then finally on the
seventh round we're actually done okay
so the value that X took on here is
seven because it took seven rounds for
this whole table to be
filled okay did I go to on that people
good do we understand the premise
here
Nots all right cool so the question is
what is the expected number of
rounds all right okay uh maybe turn to
your neighbor talk about it come up with
some pretty come up with some uh good
ideas for random variables that we can
use here to try to solve the expected
number of rounds um few good a few good
considerations are like maybe there's
something geometric in there maybe
there's something like a binomial
looking in there all little all little
suggestions but uh yeah it's uh this is
not an this is not like one could
probably yeah one could probably think
of it like a span like with fresh eyes
can think of it like a span of like a
few minutes but like it's it's pretty
it's the one that we have is pretty
hardish okay go for
it
trial
we CRA
br
that
that's
and then
I
do you guys want a little bit more time
or think we think we could take a stab
at
it oh all
right so okay so who's got a good
suggestion tell tell you what uh for
these ones I'll give out I'll give out
Chate chocolate
truffles okay uh yes I don't know if
it's a good suggestion but I was
thinking like can you speak up a little
bit I don't know if it's a good
suggestion but like if we have buckets
you can like think of like each bucket
as being success I was think like a
geometry where each bucket be a success
for that one a lot of them like
ative great suggestion so I like that so
there's I heard like sum of geometrics
some of some something about binomial
they're very good um the only issue with
the binomial is it assumes that they're
independent of each other yeah I was
thinking like a negative binomial
because negative binomial is some
geometric I know some
geometrics yeah but then you need to
like I had the same thought last night
and I was trying to I was trying to see
if I could explore it a little bit more
but I think the so the way that the
approach that we actually have is like
pretty close like a to a negative to a
negative binomial but it's uh at stages
it's kind of quite quite close here can
can you can you pass this back can you
pass this back oh yes
yeah uh to the general over there in in
teal gray blue huh
okay thank you okay uh what if we did a
summation of different geometric random
variables where the first geometric the
probability of a success being picking a
new bucket is exactly one so we're for
sure going to get a success and each
subsequent round the probability lowers
therefore the expectation of the
geometric 1 over p is going to get
greater and we just add all those
up okay yeah I'm pretty sure that that
that's 80% of the solution we can go
with that so suggested was using a
geometric at each round
um and say that quantify success as a
new bucket at every single round so what
this means
is the let XI be the number of Trials to
get a success after the I success okay
so what does success here mean success
is hashing strings to previously empty
buckets okay and after I buckets have
like greater than one strings prob like
we can calculate the probability of like
of a success as being like nus I / n let
me clarify what that
means so we have a string we have some
partially filled area here there's uh I
like here I equals 3 there's five
buckets and we have and we have this
region over here of like three kind of
like consecutive buckets of just like
emptiness I put them consecutive they
don't have to be consecutive but they're
just there it was easy to to
draw um so here we see that like the
success the success here will be like
hitting any one of these three buckets
okay and the geometric variable that
we're going to be looking for here is we
want so we already have like ey strings
that are like in that are like like
there's already two two successes here
there's two of them right there's like
two buckets that have strings already
they theyve satisfied our criteria and
the probability that we're going to hit
that like we're going to hit any of
these is n minus like IID n which is
going to just be like three fits okay so
that's the probability that we're going
to be successful at every round from
whatever the I round is that we have
here did I say eyes or something okay I
just realized okay anyways
so the so the random variable we're
going to choose is a geometric and it's
going to say okay after the third round
what is what is the expect amount of
time until I throw like a piece throw a
string into one of these bottom three
buckets okay does that make sense this
is like the critical this is like the
critical piece like this is this
probably like this single like this
single little thing here like this
little like thinking of this really
creative random variable probably took
like many hours of trying or or like I
don't know take
takes
nothing okay any questions like I don't
want to lose people at this
one
yes yeah okay so I have a there here's a
typo round here so I I wrot the round
here is like I I should be two here the
round the rounds are like I counted
rounds and number of buckets as a even
though they're not so this is uh like
the these these sides are like really
like the yeah the these sides that this
is supposed to be a two I'll like I'll
correct them before before we post this
but should yes so to clarify What's
Happening Here is that we're studying a
bunch of geometric functions and we're
summing the probabilities together
because every single time you know the
the chance you're going to fill an empty
bucket is going to be yeah and so we we'
only sum five abilities this time uh for
this
one five geometrics not just five right
because you could
like actually yes you some five
geometrics but the chance you have
multiple rounds but like is it five no
it's not five on the fifth round the
chance of success is one5 so the
expected is one over 1 or five expected
trials
M sorry could you repat that
it's like you wouldn't you sum five
different GE for example on the first
round the expected number of Trials is
one because the probability of success
is one one over one is one the fifth
trial the probability of is 1 yes you Su
end so you Su you sum for the number of
buckets that that you have I I have yeah
yeah you do some you do some numbers the
thing that was unbounded is um the
geometric itself is unbounded because it
could take you like an infinite amount
of time to actually hit each one of the
buckets yes how do we
yeah where does where does p come from
where does p come from yeah what do nus
oh n minus n minus I is just a number of
buckets that don't have a string in it
already and then divided by n is like
the probability that you're going to hit
any of those of those probabilities for
this one partic for like the next round
oh yeah yeah okay okay all right let's
move
on so okay here's the full geom here's
like the full like like geometric p p
pmf of it um your XI are going to be
distributed with geometric n minus I / n
okay so this is the main important part
the part that comes after is just a
bunch of mathy math and like there's
something there's something there's
something complicated about those but
don't worry too much about it so the
part that comes after is okay well look
it not not that part but you take the
expectation is n / n minus one as
defined by the geometric variable you
take the sum exactly as I said over here
there'll be five of them so x0 all the
way to 5 - one 4 okay because you have
five different you have like five
different buckets or here and different
buckets you some and you sum over the
probability for all of
them and then there's this thing which
is okay if we really want to compute it
each Val each one of those those X NS
has probability like n/ n like the first
bucket you're going to you're going to
fire off probability one that you're
going to that you're going to hit an
empty bucket because that's the first
thing you're going to hash then after
that I like okay now I got to Hash the
other n minus one and then after the
second round then you have to hatch like
I don't know the next like n minus two
buckets
right so this particular sum has a name
of a harmonic sum and in math and that
particular harmonic sum is some constant
times log of
n that's it there there there's no like
where there's a I I actually tried I
actually tried to figure out what that
what that o was it was actually like
bounded between like two two little log
things it was easier just it was easier
just to say okay like it's like Big O of
like n log n oh by the way the outer
nend is from like the the n in the in
the
numerator or n in the numerator I forgot
I had this
clicker
okay and yeah that's F and yeah this
part right here this part right here
will be your final answer if you get
this part right here um your grer will
be very happy to see that but that's
about it
okay all right so that's the end of the
hard part the rest of this the rest of
this lecture is going to be about uh
this one cool cool like cash farming
thing I saw um some some little things
to help you out in like 161 uh and this
one little thing about uh well not one
little thing like a pretty important
thing about um different differential
privacy okay so what did we just see we
saw expectation we saw conditioning
and let's and let as all good things
whenever it does a slide with a peanut
butter and jelly and jelly sandwich it
means we're putting the two things
together and getting conditional
expectation okay so for conditional
expectation have one um X so X and Y are
joint need discre random variables okay
recall that a conditional pmf of x given
some y some Y is use a little Y is just
this like expansion here this is by
definition of like of uh of just like a
random like conditional expectation or
sorry conditional probability okay we
Define the conditional expectation to be
okay if we have some run of variable X
and some condition we just call that the
sum of whatever value the X can take
given whatever the the value that y was
okay so this is all just like notation
no notation sugar notation syntax it
will be on the sides
right and then okay if the thing is a if
the random variable is continuous you
would take an integral instead of a
sum yeah okay like yeah the notation
like that first equation p uh subscript
like the uppercase X and Y that's just
implying like uppercase x equals Little
X
right oh yeah so in this one like we're
conditioning on like yeah like we're
conditioning on some Y and it say okay
here's a here here's like if I give you
X and I give you y this is like what the
like what the this is how you can
evaluate what the probability is yeah so
it's like the notation like the
subscript
notations oh sorry you mean this Oh you
mean this part yeah exactly that that's
just like which which did distributions
are they're drawn from because it's kind
of long to write this whole thing like
board space right yes how do we get that
second line is it just
like oh no no no no no this is just a
definition we're just defining the
conditional expectation as just this as
just distinct so like theot the
conditional expectation takes some value
times the probability of that value
happening and it mult find the
probability of like that Val happening
we need a condition on y That's
it
okay all
right here's some
practice so the practice is okay we got
two six-sided die D1 D2 Define random
variable X to be the sum and Define the
random variable y to be the value of the
second dice okay what is the expected
value of x given that we know what the
value of the second dice
is
okay um yeah sure take maybe like take a
minute or two uh think think about this
for a second it should be pretty like
like should just be able to like like
just apply the definition should and it
could be straightforward but uh yeah
chance to talk to your neighbor I'll
give out I'll give out some more Kit
Kats is it too
easy
okay all right let's just uh let's get
some let's get some some ideas coming
out here okay so what what is okay
what's one thing that that we could do
here yes we just of count it out okay
yeah yeah yeah you could just count it
out yeah yep boom count it out just cck
take this GI take all these numbers
right and they like okay so you know
that six that that we have that we
starting from six just add one add two
to all of them right and then multiply
and then just multiply the probably by 1
16 and you get 9.5 intuitively this is
the same thing as just take the six that
we already got
by linearity of expectation on okay
should be D2 here but D1 and D2 same
same thing that's equal to 6 Plus 3.5
9.5 both both cases okay make sense any
questions so yeah I'm going to call him
FR it back more because like this a
okay okay so we're going to Define G of
Y is equal to expectation of x given y
okay so we want in this in this segment
we're going to highlight that the
expectation here is going to be a
function of Y so Y is like some like
predetermined thing we're going to try
to take it as a function so here's a
backbox of whatever y could be okay so
the input is okay well okay I guess we I
guess we we write that out explicitly
the input is say Y is equal to 5 okay
then what's the expectation over all the
X's given that that y was something I
haven't told you anything about like the
probability like Mass here or the
probability density here anything like
that so but this function should just
give us a number it should give us like
an like a like an exitation over X if I
tell you what Y is okay likewise if I
say Y is three okay then this function
might just tell me that it's six okay
that's it all we're trying to say here
is this part this like expectation of of
x given y equals little Y is a function
on on y okay it is not a
number okay so key Point e ofx is a
number e ofx given Y is a function and E
ofx equals like say something like e of
x equals like five doesn't really make
sense okay so like we we can't like this
is like a thing that we've like seen in
the past where where like students were
like oh yeah we we're like really out of
time on like P something we write
something like this we be like okay like
we don't really know what to do with
this okay makees
sense
okay so here's some here's a few
interesting stats that we collected like
okay I'm pretty sure these stats are
like from like five or six years ago but
still pretty relevant at least quter
Trends so here's like fa like we have a
joint distribution over favorite number
and the year in school here's the
marginal meaning like okay if we just
condition uh if we just like say okay
like ignore the year part and just take
the
take the the like the probability over
all the favorite numbers these are
people's favorite numbers everybody
likes seven because I guess like that's
a jackpot in like a casino or something
right like 777 jackpot I don't know um
my personal favorite is five I'm very
happy it's number two good
taste so how do we actually calculate
the expectation of this thing you just
sum you just sum you sum each each value
and multiply by their part by their like
uh their their pmf here okay
so okay one tricky question is like why
do we know that all of these
probabilities that that they sum to one
like what do we have what do we what do
we have to do to like make sure that all
of these like some are like some to
one yeah yeah yeah you marginalize you
normalize marginalize somewhere the wise
divide
okay all right so here is the here is
like a condition table we're like okay
so condition that you're you're a
sophomore your expected value the
expected number that you will like is
like 5.5 okay very tasteful number five
great if you're junior deviate a little
bit is you're more likely to like a
number around 5.8 senior 6.0 I think
they meant 4.0 for GPA but like two but
like six is also
fine and then if you're fifth year just
go down to
4.7 don't know maybe they maybe they
also like number five but they just uh
like undershot
it okay
everyone see what we did there so it's
hard to like we didn't want to write out
the whole joint table on like a side it
was kind of difficult so like we just we
took the we took the expected value and
used that as a
representation and that's exactly what
the what the expected value should
should
do
okay okay so um yeah this is this is
another thing on like a graph what the
pre what the previous table look like
and here is one about the expected
number of units you're going to take
given which year you are at Stanford
okay
Frost so Frost oh my God you guys are
working hard like the expected value of
a number of units there is quite high
and then you and then I think what
happens is you realize you're too hard
and try to take it a little bit slower
in like soft more year but like kind of
overshoot it a little bit and you pick a
back up in junior year right but in
junior year maybe you take a really
really hard winter it's like n no no no
never again and then senior spring all
the senior
year and then the the fifth year are
left like me are probably just gunning
for the gunning for the sorry for the
units to actually graduate so we have to
step it up a little tiny
bit all right the first time I saw this
was pretty interesting because I I think
we took the I think we took this
particular value over um all the over
like CS 109 in general so like this
particular group of like frost are like
the frost in like CS 109 and the southt
in CS 109 so it's like it's a like like
this is a distribution over like our
class in the
past yeah it's quite
yes you seen like a couple examples of
things like this sampled like culations
like where is this data and can you use
it uh figure data probably somewhere on
Chris's computer I need to figure that
out but can you guys use it sure I mean
like just yeah just like ask whoever has
it like I think send yeah send send
Chris an email we probably know where
this is there probably like some forms
and documentation around it but it
should be okay yeah great idea for a
great idea for extra credit project yeah
okay all right so I built in a little
bit of a break I don't know if it's
halftime I think I went over by 5
minutes but yeah let's give people like
a two-minute breather go use the
restroom uh come up ask some questions I
got some extra I got some extra candy
yeah how about
it
okay all right so it's been two minutes
I think if the clock is
right all right so let's uh come back a
little bit and then start talking about
the other parts that I have planned for
the rest of
lecture all right so real question what
is
this what is this
thing huh s nah it's like the
expectation of an expectation okay so so
so what is he so so like let's let's
consider expectation of x given y as a
function on Y and then I take the
expectation outside of it on y right
like what is the expected value of like
the Rand so the r this function right
here like expectation here that's a
random variable based on like whatever Y
is and then we just like expectation
over it yes like on the previous example
with the years versus the units would
that be like the expected value of like
if we were to pick one year like how
many units would we expect yeah exactly
so the expected so the expected value of
all the of okay so the expected value of
the expected value of x conditional y
trick shot or it's a it's a it's just
the expected value of
x that's it that's
it
huh it's because of this it's because of
a math trick so we actually have a proof
for it okay so
uh the the proof here the proof here for
why this for for why this for why this
Tower Property H is like okay like in
other math classes we call this like the
Tower Property it's uh pretty important
and actually like I think I use this one
time like a like a finance interview or
something was interesting but so here's
a full math proof let spew don't worry
about it for now I will go over line by
line with expect with uh with a with a
cursor and some notes so first line we
expand this using the law of unconscious
satis because expectation of x given Y
is a function of Y okay
so click great okay lav on content
satiation okay so I get this big so I
get this big
sum then by the definition of
conditional expectation I extend out the
first term okay then I use a change rule
to smash back in the probability the
probability that y equals a
y
okay and then I and then I do this
really like simple thing of okay switch
the order of the sums here because
because like there like doesn't like the
ordering doesn't matter on the sums and
this say X is not really like X doesn't
depend on anything y here right like
every single one of these y terms is
multiplied by the same X we can just
pull it
out and then we'll if we're going to sum
over the joints of all the Y that's just
going to give us the marginal on
X and if you if you just get the
marginal on X and you sum over and then
you sum over the X's here that's just
the expectation of x
marginalized definition of expectation
of X
cool yeah it's
Tower
H yeah this is Tower Property um I can I
can go back and Trace through this a
little bit more carefully uh any
questions yes could you go over the
first line again how we the
law ah yes that's because this thing
right here expectation of x given yal
little Y is a function on is a like we
can view view this as like a function on
um it's a fun on little y so whatever
the Y so whatever y value we can take
here we can just like say okay we're
going to take the xation of X over that
because this will give us a value back
it's a function
y okay make
sense
almost uh
yes can I get intuition for this by
thinking of e of X and Y a function uh
over all possible
y over all y y the expectation of that
is just expectation of X is that why
it's called to law of total expectation
yeah it's kind of like like lot of total
expectation comes out of this and it's
actually it's actually a little bit
simpler than this but the idea is like
okay we have the expectation G of x
given whatever we see on Y and then we
take the we take the expectation again
over all the Y that we can possibly plug
in over all the W yeah and then that
comes out to just be the expectation X
that's what this whole that's what this
whole statement is trying to
say yeah we have expectation of X we do
like 1 n right times all you know what
I'm saying yeah why is there not term
like that is B equation oh it's because
one/ n if you have a finite sample so
like if you're like like a sample mean
right that's a slightly so just multiply
by X when I these
up is that the is that the equivalence
it's equal it's equ yeah sorry here why
is it called the tower rule Tower rule
because I think I think the idea was
like actually I'm not even sure why we
call it a tower rule I just saw one time
we like oh yeah this is a tower property
I think it's because if you if you keep
chaining the expectations oh like like
you can like we can like make this
longer and it will still come down
collapse down to a little white here
right like we can take like expectation
of Z and then pipe in another Z into the
conditional and it'll still give you
back x m so it's you can make the left
side like you can you can collapse the
tower down to this little tiny thing all
the like anytime come on come on cursor
there it is that makes sense yeah it's
uh it's pretty cool
here
sorry
okay all right so with that here's the
LA total expectation and here's okay so
here's a little something I I prepare oh
yeah um this is key like this for the
next problem this will be the key uh
just take like uh the lot expectation is
you can condition on some y and then
time multiply by the probability of Y
okay this looks a lot like the law of
total probability except you put you put
the expectation on the posterior okay
poster means the larger
part cool all
right so here's a little something from
my past
so when I first so when I first came to
Stanford I wasn't sure if I wanted to be
a CS major or a math major and in fact I
actually wanted to do e but then I saw
this one question came up of like
okay how fast does this piece of line
does this line of code take to run and I
think I've been trying to figure this
out for the past three
years and to be honest I'm I still don't
know so Netflix streams millions of
hours of videos per day so they really
really care about how long it takes to
get a movie from their
database okay here's a qu here's a
question how long does this line of code
take say you have a movie file that's 52
megabytes that is not a movie that's
probably like a tiny episode of
something but 512 was a number that that
I like that kind of worked
here and here's some options okay like
we live in big old land in all of
introductory computer science but for
this particular segment and this
particular problem we're going to
actually talk about like real
values all right just real quick any
takers here just uh choose one of
these one right okay two all right any
take for three three three all right I
think it's
four the reason is because okay so
here's it's very cheeky it's they're all
correct because it's a random
variable let me explain why so the
reason is because I haven't I haven't
exactly told
you where this movie is like is this
movie stored on your computer is this
movie stored elsewhere okay so to see
the first one okay your your computer
has the movie file okay that's 3 seconds
you know dis C
uh read it through read it through put
load into your OS fire it off on on your
on your monitor 3 seconds seems
reasonable good computer very good
computer if it's in SoCal you got to go
through some Network Hoops the the
packet has to go to your router the
router has to go across some power lines
and some and some telephone cables to
actually get to your computer that's
going to take longer that's going to be
like 1.6
minutes okay all right so what if we go
even more extreme and go to Japan for a
file
all right great so now you go through
cell towers and you have this giant
under like under the ocean like like
pipe there's actually like a whole pipe
of like of just like of just like wires
going under the ocean here that connect
the internet from continent to
continent and you have to get the file
that way so that's going to take a even
a little tiny bit longer it's going to
take you five minutes to get the movie
right okay we just went across the world
in five minutes because of a giant
internet line
so are we
done
right actually
though somebody in space has a
computer whenever someone has a computer
the first thing that they do is watch a
movie yeah okay and when they watch a
movie somebody in
space has a
movie
okay anyways it probably takes about 2
hours to get a movie this is actually
this is actually made of number like I'm
pretty sure like even if we like linked
up all the linked up all the satellites
and do the little like Optical thing
it's probably not even two hours but
like tentative tentative like depends on
depends on how things go the next four
years maybe the site will
live
okay all right so what's the expected
run
time our alien friend is
backc so assume the file location is
distributed with the following
pmf 10% chance is on your computer
because we're going to assume that you
like don't watch the same videos all the
time 50% of the time is going to be in
SoCal because people are going to be
interested in the same movies across
California that's actually true that's
how they like do some like the
clustering for the for the for the
databases probably there in Japan okay
if it's not in Japan it's going to be in
space my example so I just put all the
probabilities into Japan okay probably
that it's in space I hope it's not in
space because that will take you a long
time to get the video and I'm not sure
which Alien made it so you can make
could you imagine coordinating a movie
with aliens man shooting that would be
terrible so what is the expected runtime
of this following line of code given
that you have these particular like
expected values for your runtime okay
yes sure yeah yeah yes please probabil
multipli by
the situation exactly so sorry what what
was your name
yes okay so was let's just multiply each
one of these like each one of these
values like three by their like
probability and then just sum them
together like law of total probability
and that's exactly what we're going to
do so for home we multiply okay get
Movie Database time I'm going to make a
very long name for it because good style
multiplied by the probabil multiplied by
the probability that it's at home and
the expectation is going to be condition
on that is in your house okay that's the
first
term do that for all the other terms and
you just plug and chug all the values
and you get the raw numbers okay
multiply them together you get six 6.25
minutes just some value out there on
average going it's going to take someone
6.25 minutes okay all right now another
interest interesting thing we can do is
okay let's take this single line of code
and actually wrap it in an if
statement so like let's pretend that
your computer actually has a cache that
can like take more like like that can
like taking more like taking more movies
okay there's a 10% there's an 80%
probability that the movie is in your
like local cash in your computer cache
and getting a movie from the cach takes
the same amount of time as getting a
movie from like your like local computer
because you know they're both on your
computer what's you expect at run time
of this so here's a trick that I that we
that I kind of want people to see is if
you have an if else statement here and
you want to take total and you want to
take expectation do total do the law of
total expectation based on a branches is
so if else here law of total of
expectation first term will come from
the if second term will come from the
else okay it's exactly this just okay
get the first get the values like here's
your first term this is from the this is
from the else okay I put the else first
and then the if second okay we already
know this value up here if the movie is
not a cash that's just a database read
right so that's just the expectation of
whatever we had from the previous side
multiply that by 6.5 add them together
1.2 okay we didn't the important thing
is we didn't have to redo the work to
get us like 6.25
minutes
okay following all right let's do one
more thing what if you have many files
so I just wrap wrap that if El statement
inside of a for Loop okay assume we are
interested in end movies assume the
retrieval time of a movie from the old
cache takes 0.3 0.3 time time what is
the expected
runtime the expected and what is the
approximate distribution of the
runtime okay approximate distribution
here we have some assume these assume
all the movies come in
IID yeah normal Central limit theorem
it's exactly normal here and then in the
normal the mean is n times the the
expectat value for each one of the
movies so n * 1.2
minutes
okay all right great so with these three
pieces combined we've actually
implemented one of these little dots so
here's a giant map of Netflix's cach
location maps that's stale out by two or
three years so they probably have less
now because I think they migrate over
the
AWS in each one of these dots is a
building called the internet exchange
point so it's just just this giant
building that hous us well servers
probably has some really good air
conditioning good place to work okay
within each one of these servers
learning a big chunk of code that we
just basically imple implemented so
especially like maybe too it's too small
to see batch load was the last example
we saw this if L statement is the
example that we saw that we saw like two
examples ago okay that's it this is the
this is how Netflix does like cash
locality for all of the databases well
okay very simplified very simplified
there's a lot more like underpinings in
it but this is kind of the general idea
of like how you of how you would do
caching
okay oh by the way here's a here's a
full code and why would they care about
the expected value the initial the
initial functions can distribute a copy
per GE per
geolocation the getting getting the
movie you can say something about like
okay the average customer could get a
could get a clip in 1.2 minutes while
the user is either watching other videos
or asleep you can do the you can do a
batch load and load all n of the of the
files or all n of the movies okay so
this is literally this is just a
concatenation of like we did this on the
third example this is the second example
this single line is like the first ex or
uh this single line is like the first
example that's
it and we're calculating the expected
value over all these and they can use
these metrics for the like video quality
team or for like other people other
people trying to stream Services over
Netflix and sell them like hey here's
some streaming capacity for your video
like we'll charge you x amount for it
and here are the guarantees that we're
going to put for they're going to put
for that like particular
stream okay those are called slos
service service level objectives not
that important this is just like like an
example to get people warmed up for like
expected for um expected values in
algorithms
okay all
right so that's it for Netflix that's it
for our little friend the alien um we
have a little bit more of a dry problem
afterwards because it's uh grounded in
theory land I shouldn't say dry actually
it's a it's a pretty interesting problem
too but it's uh there's I I couldn't
find a very good story for it other than
hey this probably helps in one in
161 okay you have your cursive
code you take each Val each time you hit
the recur recursion you take a random
variable you take a random value between
one and three if the value is one you
return three okay that's it if the value
is not one if it's two you return five
plus another iteration of your recursive
code and if and if it's not one or two
which means it's three then you return
seven plus whatever your recursive code
returns okay and then the question is
let y be the value returned by one
iteration of recurse what is the
expectation of
Y okay so the thing to note
here what do we have we have an if else
when you see an if else the first thing
that you do is a law of total
expectation okay
why does that make sense huh why does
that make sense oh because every single
time you go down an if Branch you're
conditioning on entering that if branch
and the condition I and conditioning on
like the if statement right here right
these if conditions are all are all like
random variables they're all like
condition on like whatever X takes so
every single time every single branch of
these can be thought of as like a
posterior distribution across like the
X
okay okay so just fire off the law of
total probability you have the expected
value of like okay like Y which is this
value here so Y is like recurse given
that you've seen xal 1 times the
probability that you went down this
branch and then given that xal 2 given
xal 3 etc etc you just expand out using
the law of total of total expectation
because you have an if
statement
okay so we we take each term and we can
unpack them the expected value of y
given that X is two right that's the
second if statement and it actually ends
up just being like five plus whatever
you recurse on so by linearity of
expectation you can just say Okay
expected value of five is five expected
value of a constant is a constant plus
the expected value of recurse which is
exactly what we have right
now so expand all of
these and then we can plug them back in
by the way any questions
here people follow
me all all right
cool so we have to about so we know what
the probabilities are because it's a
random integer uniformly and we we now
know what the expected values are we can
just plug plug them in and now notice
you have you have expectation of Y on
the left hand side of the equation and
you have expectation of Y on the right
hand side of the equation but
importantly you also have a standalone
you have a standalone
constant which means that you can do you
can subtract over all of your terms of v
y and then so and then solve for solve
for E
ofy
okay so you can just subtract like okay
like the there there there is some math
unpack here but it's Mo it's mostly just
algebra you like subtract okay like a
third of a y over here you subtract like
another like third of a y over here and
then you subtract like uh like 2/3 of a
y of a expectation y over here and then
you can just see that that's going to be
equals some constant yes if we didn't
have that Standalone constant then we
would then wouldn't this imply y d of y
equals uh is like can be anything it can
be yeah uh like what if like we had e if
we just had like instead of like three
five plus recurse but this but like if
recurse if this thing then recurs if
this thing then recurs yeah like would
like we resolve the Paradox by saying
the algorithm doesn't terminate then or
like so your expected value y actually
be infinite it would it would diverge
because you would just keep summing
yeah
okay any any other questions about this
about uh did I go too fast I could go
like I could go back a little bit and
like see if there something yes in the
back yeah I think just that last step of
going from okay so this last step we
substitute in E of YX right into all of
these terms okay so we see here that
there is like a a standalone like one
like three times 1/3 is one right and
then there's like an a a term for E of Y
here there's a so one3 term for that
another third term for over here so that
makes 2/3 of a term and then here we
have another 2/3 of a term of e okay so
2/3 of 2/3 of e here 2/3 of of e here
gives us 4/3 so we can just subtract 4/3
from from both sides and get netive 1/3
of Y is equal to whatever is is equal to
like the remaining constants on the
right then you divide both sides and you
should get a value for expect
expectation
y does that make sense very hand
wavy
sort
of yeah like what I recommend is maybe
like like in your own time like take a
look at this P side and actually just
make sure that like you can solve for E
of Y here it's a very it's a very like
algebraic algebraic
computation okay yes you have question
if we modify this algorithm to say xal
random in1 2 and then we also say uh X
like if xals equals 1 then
return recurse minus one if xal 2 return
recurse plus one so that it's perfectly
balanced that that constant term cancels
out but it's still the algorithm might
or might not terminate there oh but your
expectations is going to be fine though
because it will terminate in
expectation it will terminate an
expectation yeah it will terminate an
expectation if you don't return ever you
will not you will not terminate on
expectation because there not a single
case where you would we would
terminate but if there is a case where
you could you could terminate then there
might be a chance that that in the
expectation you will
terminate I see
yeah
okay all right
so let's move on Pro tip use this a 161
this will be very useful in that class
also like on a finance interview about
like coin coin flipping but that's a
that's a that's a
tangent here's a few things about
differential privacy and maybe like the
last 3 minutes I can just go with this
like quite quickly um it will not do it
just justice so like please look at this
look at these sit on your own but like
um so here's so here's cnth at work and
she aims to like provide means to like
maximize the accuracy of like machine
learning models without like without
like with a low probability of them
actually like taking of them actually
like identifying the DAT the data set
you trained on this is particularly
helpful in medical AI where like a lot
of your data is like is like uh IR Irv
like shielded meaning like people can't
or should not be able to to look at your
training set and if you publish a model
trained on like like Health sensitive
data that's a big issue if people can
reverse engineer model to get your data
set
okay so to account for that we do a
thing called obfuscating which just
means hey for everything s we're just
going to inject a random noise into each
into like the into like the labels
and with some random probability some
training sets will just get injected
with some noise
okay and then we TR a model on it so uh
someone might actually ask us okay
what's the expectation that someone
could actually take like extract the XI
here like in in equation like this right
and what we see is that like okay this
random over here is like it's like a
Boolean between true and false what's
the expected value of whatever the
output is we get here that's just equal
to the probability that like okay so e
of x i equals like probably that y
equals 1 which because they're both of
these both of these are are
beri probability is like okay to law of
total probability if else Branch if
Branch you get the you get the 1/4 else
Branch you get whatever the original P
was
okay sorry
okay then if you then okay so say
someone say someone went in here took a
sum over all of the over all the values
like they ran your model many many many
times and then they took like some
sample average what they be to extract
out whatever this P value is turns out
they could get some
estimate they could say that the
expected value of like whatever the Z is
is equal to like 50 * P plus 25 how good
is this estimate that's an open research
problem and it's being explored by
Omar Walmart wrangled yeah the guy that
used
154 okay so that could be a challenge
you could use this as like a like extra
credit like extra credit project or so
but it's something that
exists and then and here's here's the
paper that was that was written about
this and it's still like yeah it's an
active area research differential
privacy is a big thing um I did a
project about differential privacy back
in 229 it was really fun uh it's a good
area just this is just like another way
to like use uh to use um expectation in
like Al algorithmic
analysis okay so that's it um today we
ended the algorithmic analysis part of
Cs
109 um next Monday we will start doing
machine learning
so ml Maps the all the all all the all
the big names they're they're really
cool a very fun it's a very fun section
thank you guys thank you guys for for
coming have a good
[Applause]
weekend